what the [ __ ] do architects actually do
surely it doesn't take six months to
draw some lines on a piece of paper
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
today we are breaking down exactly what
an architect does from start to finish
and believe it or not it is a lot more
than just draw 2d lines on a piece of
paper so i've spent a significant amount
of time putting this video together
putting this
very detailed flowchart i'll call it
together which are actually used in
practice to train some of our grads it
is a fundamental step-by-step guide of
what an architect does and if you're
interested in becoming an architect
hiring an architect or simply just
interested in what architects do this
video will more likely give you more
information about architects and what we
do from a day-to-day basis than any
other video on the internet and i can
quite confidently say that because i
don't think there's many people out
there giving away this sort of
information so i hope you enjoyed the
content and without further ado let's
dive right into it alright so as you can
see on this flowchart that is zoomed out
to about six percent of its realistic
size
there is so much work that's involved
and so much work that goes into an
architect's position to be able to take
your project from the moment they meet
you to actually moving in to whatever
that might be it may be a residential
project it may be a commercial project
but either way there's a lot that
happens in between so starting at the
very top we are talking about the client
acquisition we're talking about the
introduction between the architect and
the client being in person be it over
teams over zoom whatever it is it is
about getting to know you getting to
know the project and establishing those
fees so that is relatively generic it is
very simple but even the client
acquisition and the fee proposal stage
of this flowchart you can see directly
here in front of me that it is a rather
complicated procedure before we even
begin drawing there is a serious amount
of work that has to go in to
understanding what we're actually
designing for example a written design
document brief as you can see over here
is a critical element of the whole
design process we have to tease out what
you're looking to design before we know
what we're designing so that document is
ever growing ever evolving and
eventually becomes what you're looking
for now let's say we've presented you
with a fee proposal you've accepted it
it's all good we're going to move on to
sketch design once we move on to sketch
design the first thing we're going to do
is establish a feature survey of that
site that can come in a number of
different forms it can come from you
directly or it can come from a surveyor
that surveyor is going to provide us
some digital data that we can import
into our 3d software for me personally
that is archicad which allows us to
understand the contours and the levels
of the site the site is complex even if
it seems flat it's definitely not flat
so what we're looking at understanding
is the boundaries the power poles the
underground services and anything that
might be an issue for us later down the
track that feature survey is always done
before we even start drawing once we
have that feature survey information
then we begin actually drawing not many
architects still draw on paper but there
are still some out there that do a
phenomenal job so it doesn't matter what
your first sketch paper or digital it's
going to be something exquisite the
first sketch is always something that we
have no idea what we're presenting to
you we don't know if that's your brief
truly if that's your budget truly but
it's a starting point it's where we
actually understand
what you're looking at what you want and
how we can move forward in that project
together now after we establish that
sketch design have the meeting with
yourself and anybody else that's
involved in that project very early on
then we can move on to design
development design development is the
second part of this project where we
continue to draw yes there's a lot of
drawing and start but
after this design development it gets a
lot more political very similar to
sketch design the design development
phase is really working through that
architectural plan understanding all the
rooms the spaces the colors the grand
scheme of the architecture we don't get
into too much detail here we're not
picking any selections we're not picking
any fixtures or main colors internally
we're just focusing on the outside and
the position of our walls now let's say
all of that was quite simple we've
mastered it we've moved on it becomes
even more complicated if we're
discussing a residential project versus
a commercial project so residential
project for example would start engaging
three different consultants we'd
undertake a bowel assessment which is a
bushfire attack level if it's in a
bushfire zone an energy efficiency
consultant and also a structural
engineers quote if it's commercial on
the other hand well things get a little
bit more complicated let me just zoom
out a little bit here for you before we
break it down this is the commercial
strain that makes up all of these
consultants so once we start getting
into a complex commercial project that's
where an architect's
real understanding of project management
contract administration documentation
and the whole journey from start to
finish of that building and the life
cycle
is critical if the architect isn't
experienced enough to know what happens
when and when something is due then the
project can cause some sort of problem
some sort of delays so if we look back
into it once again we use those three
same consultants we started with
residential they're still required in
commercial especially our structural
engineer
next we might have an ncc consultant
which is your australian construction
standards and they sign off on that
final design so flow pressure test is
also required soil classifications
acoustic landscaping planning traffic
waste management they are just to name a
few all of these consultants usually the
architect is in charge of if you haven't
hired a specific project manager however
architects have been doing this
historically for decades so they are
very very good at coordinating a team
and most of them have built a team that
they all know and they all trust so when
you're working with an architect you
usually work with their team unless you
request to specifically work with an
individual now the best thing about
working with the architects team is
understanding that that architect has a
good relationship with them if something
goes wrong if something isn't done
correctly or on time the architect has
the ability to actually draw in that
consultant and get it done properly so
working with a fresh consultant that's a
lot harder working with an existing
consultant with an existing relationship
becomes a much easier challenge to take
on but it's the architect's job at the
same time to review all of those
consultants drawings and engage anybody
further so for instance the ncc
consultant might tell us we also need a
fire engineer which takes it a whole
nother level above what we used to do
before fire is getting more and more
complex every single year because safety
standards are getting higher
understandably
but it is the architect's job to
coordinate all of these drawings all of
these people's information and make sure
it flows on site so when the builder
comes on site they know what they're
doing it's all conveniently laid out and
there's no major clashes now i'm not
going to sit here and preach that i'm an
expert and that every single drawing
that i've sent out of my office is 100
correct and there's not a single clash
and every single detail was 100 correct
that is near impossible to do especially
if the project is on a time sensitive
scale most of the time if there isn't
anything major and we've coordinated it
down to the very minor details that most
things can get resolved instantly on
site that is a fantastic result however
if there is major major issues then
obviously somebody hasn't done their job
correctly along this process of 12 or so
consultants that could be even more so
now imagine you've engaged 12
consultants 13 including the architect
that's 13 extremely qualified
professionals to bring one project to
life the architect has coordinated all
of that all of the professionals have
provided their input their guidance and
you're receiving an incredible amount of
wealth and knowledge next you actually
have to get that documentation ready to
go to a council submission and be
approved by the government this is where
it gets even more complicated and even
more challenging the architect usually
works with a planner quite closely here
to make sure that is approved either
directly through council or through some
sort of council-approved system so here
in western australia for example we have
the jade app which is the joint
development approval panel it is
basically a series of five professionals
that review the project on its merits
and approve it or deny it it is a very
strict and very complicated process so
it is not something that you want to
play around with between sketch design
and final design architects are still
drawing continuously but a large chunk
of their work and especially my work as
a lead architect is making sure
that all of these steps are done
correctly all of it is communicated
correctly all of it is coordinated
correctly and that you're kept in the
loop all of the time now if you're
finding this video very informative then
there is a link down in the description
to the
davidtomich.com.edu store which will
link you directly to my website that
showcases a number of architectural
assets so anybody in the architecture
industry students professionals alike
will find some great value in that store
if you're looking for some absolutely
free content if you wait five seconds on
that site you'll get a free arcade
training session and if you want to join
an ever growing community of architects
and professionals in the industry there
is also a discord link down below it is
100 free it's just a whole bunch of
people from all over the world helping
each other grow and making sure that the
next generation of architects is even
better than the last now let's say
everything has gone to plan we've made
it through the council the government
has approved it we have the green light
to start documenting this project ready
for construction well even though we are
more than 50 of the way through it is
still a very complicated procedure down
the end and this is what genuinely takes
time because it is where most of the
information comes from so even though
this section looks like the smallest 25
in reality it is a solid 40 to 50 of the
project if not more depending on the
complexity of it so once we go into
working drawings we start to actually
engage with our consultants even more we
start to break it down even more if it's
residential we do three main consultants
where we continue to coordinate the
project if it's commercial it's all of
the consultants i mentioned before
documented to a hundred percent
completion ready for the builder to walk
on site we'll have multiple meetings in
between with the client just to make
sure we are still getting things correct
and that nothing is missed along the way
there are two options once the
documentation is completed or nearly
completed you can go directly out and
start building with a builder or you can
actually tender it out through the
architect the architect will compile all
the documentation and tender it out to a
number of builders to try and attempt to
get you the best price possible if we
are coordinating it out for a project
tender and to a series of builders that
means we are coordinating a number of
new documents allowing four weeks for
the builders to price it continuously
negotiating with the builder
understanding their requests answering
rfis and making sure that whatever
questions or needs that they may have we
are able to communicate answer and
distribute everybody in that tender to
keep it a fair and ethical tender once
those tenders come back in we sit down
with a client we have a conversation
about the prices the different builders
and the options that are available on
the table eventually we sit down and we
select the one builder that we believe
is the best one moving forward for that
particular project
in that instance we then start working
with the builder we complete the
documentation 100
and all our consultants do the exact
same thing
if that's in a residential project it
isn't very many consultants if it's in a
commercial project it is all those 13
consultants we've mentioned before
including ourselves as the architect
leading the project residential is quite
simple most of the time it isn't
required to go to the fire department
and you can bypass most of this 15-day
waiting period and you can jump straight
to a building permit and start
constructing on site there is the
optional added extra of contract
administration so the architect
continues to stay onto the project even
though all the drawing is done there
isn't a single line to be drawn for a
very very long time but the architect's
role now is to make sure what is drawn
on that piece of paper is exactly what
that builder is going to build and for
the price that we originally negotiated
on yes sometimes there's going to be
some variations some are justifiable
some aren't the architect's role here is
to understand and be fair and reasonable
in that situation to be able to say yes
this variation is accepted here you go
mr builder or mrs builder you can have
an extra ten thousand dollars or
absolutely not you're trying to wrap the
system that variation is not going to
happen so the architect's main role here
is again to contract administrate to be
able to provide a fair and reasonable
middle person between two emotional
parties invested financially and
emotionally the same principles apply in
a commercial project the contract
administration is always available
however there is 90 of the time a
defense or a department of fire
emergency services which is a fire
brigade waiting period and a commercial
project can take a significantly larger
amount of time to complete up to the
point where a builder can start on site
compared to a residential project so
overall if i zoom back out that is an
incredible amount of information that
i've just passed on to you guys i hope
that basically outlines what an
architect does to be able to get your
documentation from that first initial
point of contact where we meet for the
first time to the very very last second
where we hand over the keys and you move
in to whatever it is you're designing
now each one of these little bubbles has
an insane amount of more work behind
them they aren't simply yes or no
bubbles but for the purposes of this i
thought that this flowchart would really
be able to instill some sort of
information to the general public of
what an architect does how much work
goes into it why architects are still so
valuable in a world that is moving
quicker and quicker every single day
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video if you did make
sure you smash the like button smash the
subscribe button and if you have any
questions feel free to leave them in the
comments down below that is all from me
so like always i'll see you next monday